the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only
mode okay good morning everybody um
thanks for taking the time out of your
uh Tuesday morning this is uh October
13th 2020 my name is Michael BOS from
orderflows and I'll be talking about the
new advances in orderflow analysis so my
goal for you today is to give you a
blueprint to understanding what is
happening in the market right now based
on what you see so you can make better
more informed trades with near zero
orderflow trading
experience okay
so in this training you'll discover an
easy way to trade with orderflow Trends
to easily detect Market weakness to
master trading current value and easily
identify aggressive
trading and if you stay until the end
you'll get a free copy of my book
trading order flow and when you stay at
till the very end it's going to teach
you how to determine what institutions
are doing it's going to talk about how
not all prices are the same how to limit
your risk on a trade how to determine
price rejection understanding value in
the market and much much
more so you know before we get started
if you have a problem with the sound you
may have to log out log back in um I
could hear my I know the sound is
working fine I could see it on the
computer here but you know occasionally
sometimes people get in a little bit
early and you can't hear the sound but
that's okay um you could just log out
log back in so what makes orderflow
analys is different from other forms of
market analysis well orderflow analysis
gets the trader as close to what is
happening in the market as possible and
you know for some people that may be
sort of A New Concept to grasp right
because most Traders we like to just
look at charts and you know you don't
think about getting close to the market
you know in the old days when there was
a trading floor um you know people paid
hundreds of thousand dollar hundreds of
thousands of dollars for membership so
they can stand on the floor and be in
the pit where the market was doing its
price Discovery where the bid and the
offer was trading as opposed to being
off the floor you know where you're
paying you know a broker to send your
order into the pit the people on the
floor the traders in the pit were as
close
to the bid offer because they were the
bid offer you know when you're you're
trading on a screen it's a bit different
now you know most people they just
follow the price but if you're watching
the order flow you understand how it's
trading because you know the second part
is gauging the tendency of Market will
continue in a direction right new
trading activity which is the volume
right which is the orders coming into
the market is what's going to move the
markets right markets don't move because
oh we we sold off to a um a fib level or
we we rallied to the vwap now the
Market's got to react it's the constant
flow of orders that are coming into the
market and being traded by the Traders
that's what's going to move the
market and the third part of orderflow
it basically gives you better more
complete information than 99% of the
Traders out there who are only looking
at the open high low close and you know
maybe the volume at the time you're
going to be able to see what other
Traders are not paying attention to
right you always everyone always talks
about you have to have an edge in the
market you know if you have something
you know if you have a piece of
information right we're we're sort of in
the information business you know as
Traders we're trying to capitalize on
information that other people don't have
access to and orderflow gives you that
information and best of all I'm going to
show you how you can do it without past
trading experience you know without
using complex mathematical formulas
without complicated technical analysis
without macro fundamental analysis
without algorithmic trading tools more
importantly without programming skills
right you can learn to read the order
flow and reading the order flow is just
like learning to read a book right
you're going to be able to understand
what the characters are doing in a book
just as you're going to be able to
understand what Market participants are
doing in the
market so for those of you that are new
to one of my presentations my name is
Michael Volos right and and I just want
to go through you know sort of my past
experience my trading experience you
know I've had over 25 years of trading
experience I started on the CME floor
with Dean Whitter and I spent a couple
years down on the floor in the currency
quadrant and I realized that electronic
trading is the future and a spot opened
up on their what was called the Globex
trading desk because you know before it
just used to the pit would open at 7:20
and close at 2:00 and then after that it
would go Electronics starting I believe
at what like uh 2:30 or 3:00 I can't
remember now so long ago and run until
the next morning around uh currencies I
believe closed at 6:45 a.m. or 7:00 so
long and then you know it would give
people time to roll the book to the
floor and I realized know that was going
to be the future of trading and you know
I want to be in it so I I left the
trading floor to go work upstairs on the
electronic trading desk after about
three or four years at at Dean winter I
left to join EDF man on their Global
macro Futures Trading desk and you know
we traded everything you can imagine
from you know isuki red beans in Japan
to palm oil in Malaysia to sugar in New
York every every commodity future
contract in the world we were involved
in after that I joined comr Bank you
know the big German bank and I was their
licensed urex Trader right before if you
wanted to trade urex you needed to have
a licens that was issued by the exchange
I was fortunate enough to pass the exam
back in the late 90s in Chicago before
the cfdc put a moratorium on it and you
know I was one of a handful of people
literally in the US trading on urx there
was very few people at the time and you
know I learned the relationship of
trading you know buns which is the
German tenure against the US 10-year
trading Dax against the e- minis at the
time and you know all these different
Market relationships that go on um you
know between International exchanges and
domestic
exchanges after September 11th I took
about six months off then I joined
Cargill
and Cargill was an interesting
experience because Cargill is a big
commodity trading firm right it's it's
if it was a publicly listed company in
the US it' probably be um probably the
second largest company they've got their
hands sort of in every sort of commodity
around the world that you could imagine
and you know they account for about 30%
of grain exports about 25% of meat
exports in the US but you know and
shipping you know they're all into
everything so I ran the Futures Trading
desk in Chicago then I sent was sent out
to Singapore to set up a trading desk
for uh Cargill when the simex exchange
decided to close the trading floor after
my four years at cargo I joined JP
Morgan in Singapore as vice president of
Futures Trading and I spent eight years
there before I left and you know I got
married I had a kid and I decided you
know I didn't want to do this anymore I
didn't want to go to the office at 6:00
in the morning and leave at 5: p.m. at
night you know I was spending more time
in the office than I was with my family
and didn't I didn't like that that
tradeoff and you know everyone thinks
about oh wow you you left a job at JP
Morgan you know why you know you there
is a work life balance right and yes
working at a firm like JP Morgan is nice
but you know you don't have that work
life balance and I know that trading can
provide that if you know how to trade
fortunately I spent 20 years trading
professionally that I was able to leave
there and trade for myself and in 2015 I
released the orderflows trader software
and what the orderflows trader software
was is you know I was trading for myself
using order flow right using a volume
footprint chart but I didn't like that I
felt limited on the analysis because you
know there's only so much analysis that
you can do in a market on your own and I
met with a programmer that understood
order flow and I said you know what take
these Concepts that I look for in the
order flow put them on a chart okay so
when we released the first order flow
software there was um there was about
four pre-programmed indicators that you
know how I analyze the order flow then
in
201 18 we did an upgrade to the order
flows Trader
2.0 and I added more tools that I used
to analyze the order flow and just
recently last month we released the
orderflows trader 3.0 which now has a
total of 17 pre-programmed um orderflow
analysis tools and you know the reason
I'm talking about this is because the
charts that I'm using in this
presentation are generated using the
orderflows trader 3.0 now it runs on
ninja Trader
8 and the reason for that is you know
there's so many different trading
platforms out there okay and for me
personally and you know my programmer
he's a ninja Trader 8 programmer and for
me I just find it easier to use you know
I'm familiar with all the other trading
platforms out there for me I my own you
know I'm not the greatest computer
person but I found ninja Trader for me
personally
um among the easiest to use and so it
just it fits nicely now again the charts
and tools I'm using in this presentation
are generated for my overflows Trader
software but what I'm showing you today
you can apply whether you're using um
you know the other software out there
like Sierra charts
or um you know if you're using you know
other even other orderflow footprint
software for Ninja Trader or if you're
using the ninja Trader software that has
you know a basic orderflow chart you can
see what going to be showing you you
just have to know what to look for so
hopefully by the end you'll know what to
look for so you'll see how you can
easily and quickly apply orderful
analysis to your trading to make better
more informed trades you know that's
what trading is all about you want to be
making good trades right not bad trades
so before we begin just a brief
disclaimer you know please realize that
trading involves risk and you know
trading Capital should be separate from
your your daily living
Capital all right right so order flow
now before we begin let's talk about
what exactly order flow is and why it's
important to understand and improve your
trading you know how most Traders view
the market is basically like what you
see here on the left right they just
look at a normal Candlestick chart or
bar chart see what the high the low was
where the market closed relation to the
open whereas an orderflow Trader is
going to be looking at the volume that's
traded at each level right and was you
know what the aggression was was there
aggressive buying or aggressive selling
you know they're going to be looking at
where the point of control you know
which is the level with the most volume
in the bar where that was in relation to
the bar there there's a lot more
information in an orderflow chart than a
simple bar chart or Candlestick chart
and you know most people think that
orderflow is reading the time in sales
or reading the dome but you know to be
honest you unless you got a chip in your
brain you're not going to be able to
make head or Tales out of a time in
sales you know the e- minis which trades
you know a million and a half contracts
a day the average trade size is like two
and a half contracts you know but two
contracts so you can imagine you know
how fast it's moving you know and you're
sitting there trying to pick up
something out of it you can't you can't
and the Dome is the Dome is okay on some
markets but on other markets it's
honestly it's pretty pretty useful uh
useless because it just keeps moving so
fast right you got to be sitting there
trying to think oh my gosh you know we
we traded two ticks up now we're back
down here what does that mean right it's
it's happening so fast that you can't
really react to it now under these
market conditions but from the time and
sales from the Dome when you organize
the data based on how it is traded you
have a lot of data points to analyze and
the three main data points of which
orderflow analysis all derives from in
my opinion is the Delta the point of
control and imbalances now the Delta is
the difference between aggressive buying
and aggressive selling point of control
is the price level in the bar with the
most
volume imbalances is when aggressive
buyers outnumber aggressive sellers by 4
to one or more or vice versa right if
you have aggressive sellers overrunning
aggressive buyers then you know you have
an imbalance and each of these is
important in its own way and it's from
these three main data points that
orderflow you know really opens up the
trading world to you so what you saw on
the time in sales what you saw on on the
dome right you could take all that
information and put it into a neat
easyto read format that once you
understand what you're looking at you
can make better more informed
trades now orderflow Traders 3.0 has 17
preprogram tools that help you
understand what's happening in the order
flow so you can see Market weakness you
can see support and resistance you can
see Market sweeping activity Market
imbalances where the immediate value is
where the aggressive trading is coming
in and much more now you can see all
this in a normal orderflow chart right a
normal volume footprint
chart but what the order flow Trader
does is it highlights those areas to you
okay again you don't need the orderflows
trader chart if you know what to look
for but honestly there's so much
happening in the market especially
nowadays you know over the last four
years since Trump's been president you
know these markets have have really been
Bonkers there there's no way to explain
it where you know trying to keep up with
what's happening everything is coming in
fast fig it's better to have a software
that's going to highlight things to you
so that you don't have to sit there and
pull your hair out trying to figure out
you know is this is there Market
weakness was there a sweep you know
what's the aggressive Traders doing Etc
you know let the software let the
computer do that work for you so the
first thing I want to talk about today
is trading orderflow Trends you know
everyone always says you know the trend
is your friend right but you got to ask
you know why does a market move up or
down you know market movement is based
on aggressive trading overt the passive
trading that's occurring right now so
remember right markets trade in a
two-way auction it's very clear when
aggressive trading is taking place so
for example right you have someone
that's buying Fruit versus someone
that's selling fruit you know the person
that wants to buy the fruit wants to pay
what they want to pay the person that
wants to sell the fruit knows what it's
valued at and they want to make money so
the person buying it you know the girl
on the left she's probably thinking you
know yeah I'll pay you I'll pay you five
for this well you know the woman that's
trying to sell it is you know no I'll
sell it to you at six well no trade's
going to happen the woman's not going to
buy the fruit or the woman's not going
to sell the fruit if the woman is five
bid and the seller offered at six for a
trade to happen for this woman to buy
the fruit either she has to lift her bid
up and pay the offer right pay the
market price at six or the seller has to
say ah you know what it it's getting
late in the day no one's really buying
fruit fine I'll sell at five okay that's
how a trade occurs someone has to get
aggressive someone has to be motivated
to want to take action do a
trade now in order flow there are
several ways to determine if there is a
trend in the order flow right you're
going to be watch the depth of the
market right the Dome you're going to
look for imbalances you're going to look
for exhaustion prints in bars or you're
going to watch for order flow sequencing
now order flow sequencing is something
that's new in the order flow Trader 3.0
but I'm going to show you how to see it
on a normal chart so you can look for it
yourself now again orderflow is about
understanding what aggressive Traders
are doing in the market right aggressive
sellers sell to passive buyers right
people that are working a bid or below
the bid those are passive buyers they're
waiting for the market to come to them
yeah they want to buy but they don't
want to pay up right they don't want to
overpay in their mind now but passive
sellers are the ones that are working
offers
okay and aggressive buyers buy from the
passive sellers but in all honesty
looking on a dome it could be very
confusing you know it's like having all
these little puzzle pieces falling into
your brain and then your brain's got to
put them all together okay I said it's
it's difficult for a lot of people but
when you use an orderflow chart you take
all that information from the Dome from
the time in sales and put it into an
easyto read format so for example
imbalances right remember what I said
imbalances when you have aggressive
buyers outnumbering aggressive sellers
by in the two-way auction by you know at
least four to one you could use whatever
ratio you like but you know most people
use 4 to one you know some people use
10: one some people use 5 to one it's up
to you and on moves up right you going
to be seeing the aggressive buying in
forms of imbalances right you can see
here right these blue arrows I got
pointing at aggressive buying right
these are imbalances you know any volume
that's traded on the offer is aggressive
buying any volume traded on bid is
aggressive selling but in the two-way
auction for example you know down here
at the bottom you have 14 against 143 in
the 2-way auction that's an imbalance
okay 88 against 2011 is not considered
an imbalance because it's not at least
four to one again if I was using two to
one that would be an imbalance but I'm
using four: one so as markets move up
right you're going to see imbalances and
that's important because if you're in a
position if you're in a trade if you're
long and you start seeing
buying imbalances coming in that's good
sign right you're probably going to want
to hold the trade longer say you were
short here earlier okay and you're
coming down then your Market just goes
sideways okay maybe you're you're short
from you know
3540 okay then down here we go sideways
at 3527 you're like thinking uh you know
is this pause are we going to continue
going down or we going to start rallying
then you start seeing the buying IM
balances okay that's not a good sign
that's your sign to get out of the trade
just as you know if all of a sudden you
got long down here at 27 27 and a half
Market starts going up and you see all
these buying and balances that's good
right you're going to want to probably
stay in the trade a bit longer as long
as there's buying
imbalances in the direction of the trend
you're
going okay and moves down this was just
this
morning all right you could see or last
night rather on 7 right as we're making
these new lows what do you see mostly
selling imbalances selling imbalances
selling imbalances as the market keeps
selling off yeah there's green bars here
right anytime you know you're at a low
you see a green bar you know sort of
your your instinct is well maybe this
Market's going to start to turn around
but do you see any buying imbalances no
you don't instead you just see selling
imbalances as the market keeps making
new lows right if you are short and
you're making new lows you know I know a
lot of times you you make a new low then
you bounce up but you can often see the
buying imbalances come in off the lows
if you don't see buying imbalances then
you know the trade is evenly distributed
but if you're just seeing selling and
balances then you know the selling is
still
strong now the second part of talking
about Trends in the order flow
is you know let me just take a step back
here um you know back in the early 90s
Tom Demar right the big technical
analysis guy um you know he's got the
sequential all that stuff you know I
remember I he I was in one of his uh
trainings and he was talking about the
last buyer Bond
or the last seller selling right when
the last buyer is bought in an up
move then the Market's got no more
follow through and it's not going to go
higher it's going to naturally sell off
just as when the last seller has sold in
and move down the market is probably not
going to go down anymore because there's
no more Sellers and in orderflow what
I've realized many years ago is you have
this exhaustion right when you look on a
bar by bar
basis what I call an exhaustion print is
you can see when the buyers because
you're looking at the volume right you
so you can see When Buyers or sellers
are exhausted as the market is moving
and on a Barby bar basis you can just
see and you know at the edges of the bar
right this is one of the ways I I used
to trade early on with orderflow well
before you know I even envisioned having
the orderflows trader software is I
would just look for bars like this that
had what I called an exhaustion print or
small single digit print you know at the
edge of a bar here you can see one
contract contract here you can see 9 3 2
and what it's telling me in this bar
there was no interest in selling at the
low of this bar right in this other bar
low of this bar one contract trade at
nine here three two there was no
interest right if people are interested
in the market going lower you know it'd
be trading decent amount of volume not
nine contracts not one but normally were
trading three four 500 contracts at a
price level that's what we call an
exhaustion print right
here right off the high of the day um
this was yesterday right
11:00 one tick off the high next Bar
opens up one contract starts trading
down each bar is what do you see on the
move down you're seeing exhaustion print
exhaustion exhaustion small digits 1 4 8
2 4 right that's what you want to see on
a move down right once you stop seeing
them then you know maybe the market is
the move is is kind of stopped as when
you get down here to around the 17 area
you're not really seeing anything and
the market just go sideways but when a
market has a chance to go back up and
test a high go back up test the high and
it doesn't and it just trades very small
contracts that's a sign of
buyers basically not really interested
in the Market at this point going higher
now later you know an hour later yeah it
can still go higher but right now right
this is why I talk about being as close
to the market as possible when you're
watching the order flow you're seeing
what's happening in this bar one
contract traded at the high of this bar
that's significant four contracts that's
significant all right and it just can't
it's just there's just no interest right
it'd be different story if there's 180
contracts or you know something else but
there's just no interest there no
interest
here now this is interesting because
this is a 10-year note chart okay 10year
notes it's a 15minute chart 10-e notes
trade thousands and thousands of
contracts at a price level sometimes you
know it trades tens of thousands at a
price level and look at this
yesterday after the high is made the
next bar it starts coming back up it
trades nine contracts nine contracts in
a market that normally trades you can
see 4,000 5,000 7,000 9,000 1,800 4,000
5,000 7,000 4,000 10,000 n that sticks
out like a sore thumb right and what
happens
now that you know that there's no buying
interest right what do you think's going
to happen Market's going to drop off
right again it's like I said earlier
right you don't need any strong
mathematical formulas to you know
calculate oh my gosh you know we got
this no oh my gosh I could see looking
at the volume it's plain as day it
sticks out like a sore thumb that it's
just nine contracts now the orderflows
trader software does highlight it to you
and it actually allows you to draw out a
Zone like this you know for so you can
sort of see you know what happens when
the market comes back right you can see
here right in the next bar again you got
five Market tests that level sells off
can't get through
it here right at 27 a half you got the
two right Market rallied up within a
tick of that and sold off a bit okay so
it's it's fascinating because you know
in the old days you know when there's a
trading floor and you know even in the
early days of electronic trading we used
to call this a high tick or a low tick
right which is and a attempt to probe
price to see if other Traders are going
to be attracted to that level to keep
trading you know or sometimes you know
if it's at a high or low to look for
stops right because you know anytime the
market is is Bid offered you know um you
know bid at the high of the day and it's
offered at the high but the high hasn't
traded sometimes you know someone will
come in and try and high ticket to
trigger a stop at at a new High um
so as well as you know if you know as
the market makes new highs Market is
going to keep going up so what what
Traders would do often times is you know
if it's bid at the high and it's offered
at a new
high you know trade one or two contracts
see if other Traders are going to you
know screen Traders people off the floor
are going to say oh my gosh you know hey
we just traded a new high I better buy
some right they're trying to sort of
suck in people to come in to keep the
market moving right keep the trend
moving so you know imagine if if the
market is Bid off bid at the high
offered at a new high a tick higher
trades one contract there that
immediately sells
off do you think the Market's going up
no that's your fading
opportunity you know now when you put
some of these tools together right like
exhaustion and imbalance right here's a
perfect example right this Market's just
coming back up towards the high and then
this bar we're about the four ticks off
the
high we've got exhaustion right you got
the single print and you got the sell
the selling imbalance one two three
imbalances in that
bar Market sells
off right it it's again it's you don't
need you know fancy indicators once you
know how to read what's happening in the
market you know things become really
easy now orderflow sequencing is is a
new thing in the order flows Traders 3.0
software and what it is
it's it's a market condition when the
order book gets eaten up with subsequent
higher volume levels so for example okay
remember this is the dome right and you
can see here on the order book right
Mark is 39 at 39 and A4 there's 98 146
232 301 357
446 so what you're seeing is a solid
order book where each subsequent level
there's more volume okay and the reason
for this is often times you know if
someone's trying to defend a level right
they're just not going to put a thousand
in here at 9 and quarter they're going
to put some at 9 and a/4 some at 9 and a
half more at 3/4 more at 40 more at 40
and a qu Etc they're going to sort stack
the order book to make it look topheavy
now the same would be said on the bid
side you know someone wanted to support
the market but as you can see here
there's only 78 then 143 then 287 then
volume drops down 183 299 this is a
whole number at 338 you know often times
at whole numbers you get more volume
then small volume here 165 158 167
so this is what I call a solidified
order book right it's someone trying to
defend the market from keep it going in
this case preferably to stop it from
going higher right maybe they they're
trying to defend a price level for
whatever reason whatever reason I don't
know all I know is they're stacking the
order book and making it heavy now if
the market trades through a solidified
order book it's a sign of a strong
Market either up or down you know I'm
dating myself here but this is the
Kool-Aid man you know when I was a kid
watch this commercial of Kool-Aid and
the Kool-Aid guy would run
through the wall and it's sort of like
that you know in the market now if
you're looking at a normal orderflow
volume footprint chart it takes a train
ey to see this but you can see here
10411 260 297 343
537 and this is a solidified order book
now this coming in at an area right this
is sort of your swing High people are
they're they're trying to defend this
area trying to keep it from going higher
above you know above the 95 96 area
okay and you'll see in here right you
don't see necessarily you don't see
these sequences right this is just 188
395 431 then 188 right down in here you
don't really see
anything happening in here you know
there's another
one up in here you know the 123 143 187
343 686 you know often times as you're
going up to a high you do run into price
defense or going into a low price
defense trying to support the market
but it takes a train die to see this
right and and this is what one of the
things that we put in the orderflows
trader 3.0 is we highlight that to you
so you can see it all right and you can
see how the market in the next bar came
right down to that level what was
resistance now become support you can
see it in here as
well right you can see the sequence here
sequence here
this was crude oil right I know a lot of
people you know don't necessarily trade
e- minis most of the charts that I use
in here are e- minis but I also want to
show you on crude right yesterday we had
this big
selloff in crude where it dropped like a
dollar in you know just a few minutes
and right before that drop off what do
you see right we were going sideways in
here then you see the sequencing come in
boom right before the big selloff from
90 area down into you know the 3930 is
and below here you got another push down
with some sequencing right we just big
had the big push down someone came in
started bidding this Market but the
sellers overran that right they just ate
right through that
volume now this is a 5 minute crude oil
chart okay this is this morning the 13th
um this is around 6 between six and 7 or
6 and 8:00 right at the high of the day
you see the sequencing coming in here
here there's one buy sequence in here
but more selling selling selling as we
sell off from the high of the day at
4044 this is e- minis this is a FIV
minute chart you know whether you're
looking at a one minute chart a tick
based
chart volume based chart or range based
chart it will still appear on there if
it happens okay but again you got to
know what to look for if you're looking
at a normal order flow chart you really
got to concentrate at what you're
looking for it's like reading a d you
got to really concentrate on reading the
Dome this was early morning today this
is about um 1:30 Chicago time a right
you got that sequencing coming in right
here right before that big bar down you
know these are those bars as a Trader
where you know it drops from you know
the 25 area down into the you know 15
area 10-point move in one bar that
you're like oh gosh you know sometimes
you sit back at chart say oh yeah I just
need to catch a bar like this once a day
well with order flow you know there
there's a bearish sign up here also with
the Prominent Point of control and the
um exhaustion print here and here but
sequencing came in right here so even if
you're like well you know what I'm not
sure if this Market's going to sell off
because of this once you see the
sequencing coming in behind the bearish
Prominent Point of control behind the um
exhaustion print up here you know you
can feel fairly confident you know in
getting short here you know I'm not
saying that every bar is going to be
like this but you know as a Trader these
are those bars that you just love to get
right because you everyone always talks
about oh you got to let your winners run
well in this case you just boom it just
drops immediately and fills you
immediately um then you know once
sideways then here's another sequencing
here and here now this just two hours
ago 9:45 at the low of the day in the e-
minis it's on a one minute chart we had
the sequencing coming in on the bar at
the low of the day right and then we
rallied
right up from that rallied up follow
through look at this right this is what
I talk about being in a trend right
understanding what's happening right you
got your reason for getting long right
you're at your low of the day you got
Divergence you've got a sequencing and
then you start seeing imbalances coming
in on these bars buying and balance
buying in Balance buying IM balances
right so you can feel confident in
writing this out longer rather than
saying well yeah I've got my you know my
twoo take profit or my three-point
takeprofit if you're seeing all these IM
balances that's bullish right you're
probably going to want to hold on to
this trade a lot
longer so the second topic I want to
talk about is
detecting Market weakness Okay and like
your phone battery moves up or down
weaken over time right just like your
phone you just leave it on your your
desk whether you're using it or not and
the next thing you know the battery is
is weak orderflow can tell you when
that's happening now there's there's two
types of Market weakness there's what I
call a bearish market weakness and that
occurs when the market has been moving
higher but can't sustain the move higher
because the buying is weakening there's
also a bullish Market weakness I know
people get confused sometimes when I say
bullish Market weakness because how
could something weak be bullish but it
occurs when the market has been going
lower and lower but the selling just
tapers off and is exhausted the selling
is weakening basically right I mean the
market just can't go any lower because
there's no more selling so once you have
that weakness coming into the market in
weakness in the sense of no more selling
then the natural direction is is going
to be up so remember bearish Market
weakness Market has been going up but
buying is weakening until there's no
more strong buyers how can you tell well
the easiest way is watch the Delta is
the aggressive buying getting stronger
or weaker as the market is going up so
here we got this nice little move up
here right going sideways you come down
make a new low new swing low then higher
higher higher higher higher highs higher
lows in each bar and it just sort of
turns around right here and if you're
watching the Delta 102 72 50 35 then it
turns negative here minus
111 so if this move is going to continue
right you're going to want to
see stronger Delta right instead you're
seeing weaker Delta coming in as the
Market's move moving up 102 72 right it
made a new high but it's only 72 in the
Delta the aggressive buyers are weaker
than the previous bar then you get to
the next bar
50 all right it's still a green up
candle the Market's still going higher
just broke out of the Swing high but the
volum the Delta is smaller it's only 50
right for this move to continue you're
going to want to see a nice strong
positive Delta not 50 right you're going
to want to see 500 or something or 150
something stronger than the previous
numbers then you get up here you got
35 Market doesn't even make a new high
so you can see the buyers are weakening
by just by watching the Delta obviously
the next bar it's got the negative Delta
coming in so even though the Market's
going higher it's going higher on weaker
Delta than it turns around and the
negative Delta comes in and Market just
sells right off right as as expected
when you see negative Delta coming in
now bullish Market weakness is the
opposite right Market has been going
down but the sellers are getting less
and less until the buyers take control
of the market the selling is weakening
and again how you going to
watch and determine if it's happening is
you're going to watch the Delta see
what's happening in the Delta right you
got asking these questions right you got
to as a Trader you should always be
questioning what's happening in the
market is the market doing what it's
supposed to do in terms of facilitating
trade so here's a market right we're
sort of going sideways get the big down
bar okay minus 12 100 in the Delta and
then you just sort of rotate around back
and forth go sideways but you can see
here right you had a positive Delta here
on this red up bar then you got this
dogee bar it's minus 245 the next Red
Bar minus 228 the next Red Bar minus 51
then this green candle minus
two okay well yeah we still got the
negative Delta right which is on the
surface right if I had to make a blanket
statement I say yeah when Delta is
negative I expect the market to be
trading lower but what's happening in
the market it's actually the market is
making higher lows in in this case
higher highs so selling right after that
big initial push down they're still
selling but it's getting much weaker
right it's gone from 245 toga - 245 toga
- 228 to- 51 to minus two to plus
300 you can just see how the the selling
is the aggressive selling is been taken
over by the aggressive buying right and
then you can see how the market you know
ralles quickly you know from the 88 area
all the way up into the
90s right followed with more aggressive
buying you can see the imbalances in the
bars here obviously the positive Deltas
as well but when you see you know volume
just sort of shriveling up like that and
then turning positive you know when you
see the negative Deltas getting smaller
smaller smaller then turned positive
what do you think the Market's going to
do you think the market is going to keep
selling off no of course not right
Market is just going to keep going in
the
direction of the trade right this again
this
is
um sort of you know a concept you know a
lot of people nowadays can't really
understand this but you
know I learned this when trading on the
floor is you know when and this goes
back to being close to the market right
is on the trading floor right the market
is Bid offered right you can see that on
the screen you can see where the bid
offer is but most people are just
watching where is Price trading they're
not taking into account how price is
trading right you know if you're just
looking at this you're seeing a couple
you know couple red bars you know in a
green bar you know you're sort of at the
lows what do you think's going to happen
I don't know but you could be definitive
in your answer you see well I see the
seller is getting weak and I see
aggressive buying coming in right so
rather than getting late into a move
here by reading what's happening in the
order Flow by seeing the aggressive
buying by seeing the aggressive selling
dry up you can say yeah this Market's
got a very good chance to Rally up
rather than go sideways or sell off
right it's giving
you the better opportunity to trade
based on what's happening in the market
now there's two ways to do this right
there's the easy way and the hard way
right and the easy way is let the
computer do it for you the hard way is
sit here and you know watch the Delta on
each bar and try and figure it out you
know to me that was the problem in the
sense that yeah I can do that if I'm
just watching One Market and that's all
I'm doing I'm I'm focused watching my
screen but why not let the computer do
it for you let the computer highlight
those areas of Market weakness either
bullish or bearish and give you a sign
you know then let you make the decision
right I I don't like to necessarily
create indicators that just say buy here
or sell here you know to
me these the orderflows trader 3.0 is a
tool right it's something that says
whack me in the head Mike pay attention
to what's happening here here you got
bullish Market weakness right then you
can put the rest of the puzzle together
but it it sort of gets my attention says
Hey pay attention this Market could
Rally or here this Market is showing
bearish Market weakness it could sell
off pull the trigger depending on how
you
trade now the third part I want to talk
about today is current value right and
you this is an important topic because a
lot of Traders understand what value is
in the
market without realizing it right and we
think in terms of value every day in our
lives but we don't always think about
value when trading you know am I getting
a good deal you know if you ever been to
a vegetable market or you know a fish
market a wet
Market there's so many people selling
the exact same thing right and as a
buyer right you're going to go to the
place where you're going to get the most
value for your money and the same thing
is like that in the market right because
you know that well okay yeah I could buy
you know the lettuce here from this lady
and she's going to give me an extra
onion or something you know you're
getting value or you know she going to
give me more
lettuce you know because for whatever
reason um you know she's giving you
value you you're getting a good deal
and when you know where value is right
it's going to in the market it's going
to let you have better trade location
better trade location equals better risk
management because you have a bit more
wiggle room right you got into the trade
you know maybe you got into the trade at
the bid you know it's it's like the
difference between working a bid or
paying the market right you work a bid
you get filled you get a better fill
than buying the market now you don't
always get into a trade but you get a
better trade location and often times
it's going to give you a little bit
extra room you know when the trade
starts going against you and you it's
just going to in the long run it it
helps you much better you know because
if you're constantly getting into trades
in bad locations it just makes it that
much harder for you to profit on a trade
you
know for example you know sometimes you
know you're you're caught off sides on a
trade right trade's going against you
and you want to get out so you work a
limit order and it trades there you
don't get anything then the market moves
away you know and your loss is getting a
little bit bigger finally you just say
you know close the trade you at the
market and you pay the high of the move
or you sell the low of the move you know
that's that's a bad trade location and
often times that comes
from you know being into the trade at
the wrong location to begin with so
until now Traders have struggled with
incorporating value into their trading
on very short time frames most Traders
are familiar with volume profile or vwap
you know it's easy to look at vwap or
volume profile and identify the level to
trade around but the problem
is with vwap or volume profile is it
takes time
for a profile or vwap to develop right
if if you're looking at vwap you know
maybe starting at you know at the cash
open and inequities well you can't trade
it in the first couple
minutes because you know it's still
defining on on what VAP is is probably
going to be right where price is and
same thing with volume profile right
everyone always talks about about oh
yeah you know you got to see where the
you know the the PLC of the day is ETC
but it takes time for it to develop it's
not going to be useful right now or you
could be so far away from that value
either so far away from vwap or so far
away from you know the value area the
value area high or value area low that
it's just not going to be useful for
your trading right now right you want to
know where value is right now if you're
trading a one minute time frame if
you're trading a five minute time frame
Etc
now you know a lot of software allows
you to put volume profiles on your chart
and you know and they're useful so this
is a 15-minute e- mini chart and you can
see
here you know the market volume profile
has been rallying right we've been
getting a lot of um nice profiles to
trade but the problem is again you know
there could be instances you're so far
away from value like you know on these
days we're outside of value right and we
don't really even come back in to test
the value areas so yeah okay we're above
value so you know you're looking for a
certain type of activity to happen
Okay it can happen it cannot happen
right
it's then you sort of got to you know
when it gets into this point when you're
so far away from value versus the
previous day then you're not even
looking at you know value in that sense
you're just looking okay what are we
doing right now and it just makes it a
little bit harder so you know on vwap
you know vwap is a great tool a lot of
Traders use it and you know a lot of
Traders think it's the holy grail for
some reason but you know it's
basically a volume weighted average
price that's all it is and you know I
know a lot of Traders like to trade you
know when we come back to VAP you know
we're going to hold it or you know break
through it Etc but you know there's days
where we just spend all day above vwap
so you know if you're the type of Trader
you're looking for the reversion to the
mean you're not getting it so you got to
sort of alter your trading plan or or or
stop using
it now knowing where current value is is
going to help you understand what's
going on as we start to move away from
that value it's better to have current
value than value built up over the day
if you're trading in the short term if
you're trading on a one minute
chart you know looking at a volume
profile for the day there there are some
times where it's going to be very useful
but most of the time it's honestly it's
not going to be useful you know if
you're trading a longer time frame a
15-minute chart a 30- minute chart yeah
it could be very useful for you but you
know on a very short time frame it's
usefulness decreases in my opinion now
you can do is you could look at the
value area for the individual bar and
use it in relation to current market
activity now the Overflow is Trader
software I know you can do it on a lot
of software you can actually draw the
profile the volume profile like this for
each individual bar okay but I found
that
very not hard to deal with kind of
annoying actually because you have all
these different colors you know drawing
over every bar and on what I did on the
orderflows trader software you can do
that with you you can draw the profiles
but I said just put a box around the
value area right you can see these gray
boxes and there's going to be that just
unlocked so much more information for me
as a Trader because I know about trading
value on volume profile and Market
profile but on the smaller time frame
charts right you can take what you know
about volume profile what about Market
profile and now apply it on micro charts
so to speak micro in the sense of time
sense you know on a minute by- minute
basis so you can see here right we got
this this area right this
forming over you know almost uh what is
that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
bars right eight minutes where the value
is just sort of holding right it's a
little you know you're forming this
bigger value area on a longer time frame
but you can see it forming here going
sideways and more importantly as you
start to come out right now two things
are going to happen right you're trading
below value right you're going to look
for the responsive activity right for
the rotation back into value you get a
little bit of it but no follow through
so what do you think it's going to
happen rejects the value area and sells
off and you can see how it's working in
here with the selling imbalances as you
start to break
away you know now some people will say
well I don't need know value areas we're
just going sideways well yeah okay but
you know what are you going to do you're
going to bracket the market put a stop
in here buy stop and sell stop Etc and
by the time the market moves away you
know you're you're down here right
you're already well below
this you can safely say okay well I see
here you know this is our value area for
the for right now over the last 10
minutes we're trading below that value
area right here coming in
1029 if you get a rotation back up there
yeah hey you know what I might want to
put a short in here you know if I get it
great I can catch a move down if I get
stopped out you know my Stop's just on
the other side of this sort of this
value area right so it just gives you it
unlocks a lot of probab uh possibilities
you know here's another example this is
yesterday morning right in the E Mini on
a one minute chart right we just want
sideways here you can see in here a lot
of value right basically you know again
the market is going sideways you're
going to see value areas sort of bunched
up but where it gets
interesting we got two bars here at the
end of this area where value is finally
broken out then it rotates inside okay
now at this point all right when you're
trade above value and you trade back in
it's got to it's either going to hold or
it's going to trade right through
eventually but what do you see you see a
gap here a big gap in the value here's
another Gap in the value area here you
don't really see gaps they're really
overlapping so you know as value markets
look for Value right and when you start
seeing the value areas just gapping away
that is a bullish sign if they're
gapping to the upside or bearish sign if
they're gapping to the
downside now another way to use
it is look at on a bar by bar basis so
there's three bars here bar one bar two
bar
three bar one and two or sorry bar one
and
three is examples where the current bar
opened above the previous Bar's value
area closed below it all right that's
bearish that was on bar three you can
see here we opened up above the previous
value area closed below
it now bar two it's kind of similar but
just deals with the individual bar bars
one and three deal with the previous
bars value area bar two is we opened
above the bars value area now you're not
going to know where the value area is
till the bar closed but what it do we
closed below the value area for the bar
that's also
bearish right the same thing would be
true if it was bullish right if if these
were green bars right if we opened up
below the bars value area and closed
above it that would be bullish just as
if this was um you know a a green bar
this bar three was green right if we
opened up below the previous bars value
area it closed above the previous bars
value area that would be bullish as well
right this was yesterday you know
yesterday didn't Monday didn't give a
lot of short opportunities but you can
see here at the high you've got bar one
we opened above the previous bars value
area closed below
it what happens we went sideways before
we sold off this was a quick short
didn't I said yesterday didn't give many
opportunities to sell bar two similar
right what I was talking about earlier
on the previous slide we opened above
the bars value area closed below it now
with this type you know this bar two
type we're not going to know until the
bar closes where value is in the bar but
when we open on one side of value and
close on the other Market's got a very
good chance to to continue in that
direction so as you can see knowing
where value is in a bar on a bar by bar
BAS basis opens your eyes to Market
activity youve never thought of before
again there's so many questions that
knowing where value area is is going to
answer and to help you incorporate value
areas into your trading the order flows
Trader we've created a tool to highlight
value areas that are bullish and value
areas that are bullish now this is just
one way to do it and you know again
there's so many different types of value
area analysis that you can do on a bar
by- bar basis that is going to put your
trading on another level in my opinion
is just going to help you unlock what
you're seeing in the
markets so if it's bearish right it'll
print the value
area as red if it's bullish it'll print
the value area as blue right and that's
different than the rest every bar has
got a value area which is just this gray
in here the point of control is the
darker
gray so you might ask yourself you know
can you use that in your trading and the
answer is yes especially when you see
these value areas that are bullish and
bearish coming in around highs or lows
swing highs or swing
lows
now the next part I want to talk about
is aggressive trading right you want to
you as a Trader as an orderful Trader
you always want to be looking at what
the aggressive Traders are doing because
aggressive Traders are the ones who move
the market for markets to go up
aggressive um buyers need to outnumber
the passive sellers for Market to go
down aggressive sellers need to
outnumber the passive buyers now
orderflow is about understanding what
the those aggressive Traders are doing
remember for Market to move someone has
to be aggressive either the aggressive
seller has to sell to a passive buyer or
an aggressive buyer has to buy from a
passive
seller now aggressive trading is going
to show up in several different pieces
of data it's going to show up in the
Delta it's going to show up in the
imbalances it's going to show up in you
know in the actual footprint you know if
you're analyzing the bid volume versus
the ass volume and Market sweeps okay
Market sweeps is sort of a combination
of a few of those things the imbalances
and the volume now really simply you
know Delta as a market is selling off
Delta will be negative as you can see
here Market sold off it's mostly
negative Delta as the market rallied
here you see positive Delta as the
market sold off you're seeing negative
Delta you know
that's a a crude
rudimentary way to use Delta right but
you know generally it's pretty accurate
there's nothing wrong with that
imbalances you know as a Market's move
up you're going to see buying in
balances as the markets move down you're
going to see selling in balances so
here's yesterday as we keep rallying
right you're seeing a lot of buying
imbalances buying more much more buying
imbalances than selling imbalances okay
you could add that with the uh looking
at the Delta you know it gives you a
couple things that you can really use in
your
trading but the one thing I want to talk
about is sweeping the
market and you know like the Cobra Kai
thing you know sweep the leg Johnny um
you know we've been using that term ever
since you know I've been trading
electronically because you know the old
NX comx access trading system had a
function in there for sweeping normally
what you would do you know like on
Globex you just buy it through a price
but they had a function where you could
sweep a particular quantity and and go
through there now a market sweep is when
a Trader goes in and buys or sells a big
qu quantity over several price levels at
once so for example in this market is
trading 3339 bid at 39 and a quarter
okay now a big Trader is very bullish
and aggressive right he has a thousand
contracts to buy he knows the size can
affect the market and he doesn't want to
chase the market higher so what's he
going to do he's going to sweep the
order book right he buys 1,000 contracts
up to 3340 and a half okay now big
Traders institutional Traders they're
really concerned with just the average
price they're not concerned with oh I
bought 120 at this price 268 at this
price no just give me the average price
you know okay your average is you know
3985 but what's happened now is the
Market's trading 3340 a half he's net
long on an average price at 3985 and now
we're trading 40 A5 so he's happy
because he had a big order he wanted to
get done you know people going say oh
who buys a thousand actually a lot of
big Traders by
500,000 2,000 3,000 you know 1,000 right
now based on the notional value is what
170 million
um dollars okay so if you're managing a
portfolio of two or3 billion you know
$170 million as a hedge isn't uh out of
the realm of possibilities it's quite
normal and if you're watching a dome you
can see it right if you're glued to the
Dome and you no notice what that that
you just had that jump right but it's
hard right if you're watching it in real
time you really got to know what to look
for so this is e
minis right we hit the high of the day
and what do you think's going to happen
at the high of the day we can go higher
or we could to be attracting Sellers and
maybe sellers could come in it's hard to
see Market sweeps in real time and this
is you know one of the things that is
important to me as as a Trader because
you know I want to see things that other
people aren't necessarily seeing in the
market and we've devised a way to
determine if there is this sort of
activity happening and you can see here
right there's some sweeping activity up
in here here the sweep is basically the
result of a market moving very fast okay
because what's happening okay someone's
got you know a thousand you know even
some markets you 50 Lots is considered a
sweep already um it really varies on the
market but you can
it's interesting to see where they're
coming in okay so you can see here right
we just hit the high of the day start
selling off aggressive Trader coming
someone just sold it down whacked it
down basically four price levels right
and then the selling continued on down
down down from you know the 32 areas
down into the 20s now Market sweeps and
stacked imbalances often overlap because
they're both aggressive Market Behavior
where it gets juicy is when a sweep
occurs and there's no stacked imbalance
okay so for example this is crude this
is a five minute chart
you can see some sweeping activity down
here and down here preceded the market
moving
up this was yesterday in the crude again
also a f minute chart you see a a small
sweep here a sweep here and a sweep just
starting in this big bar down right
often times you see sweeps right if if
there's an economic number or you know
someone from the FED said something
often times you see someone just coming
through you know you oh gosh you know
S&P is just dropped 10 Handles in a
second someone swept through the market
right that's what they're doing sweeping
happens very often so you want to be
able to determine when they're happening
right if you can see the sweep happening
right here preceding this bar where it
just drops you know 70 cents in a few
minutes you're going to be happy right
those are those trades these are these
bars you want to be short on you know
coming into the bar now it's not going
to say every time you see a you're going
to get a big selloff like that you still
got to put in a stop to protect you but
you know these are those bars that you
know you sit back and think you know
this is why I love trading because being
able to see this activity happening in
the market just puts you ahead of
everybody else so wow I've been on here
for an hour so this past hour hopefully
you'll agree it's been time well spent
now I can't cover everything in a
60-minute training
session but I got a special offer so you
get everything you need to know about
orderflow and if you act fast I'm going
give you a very special deal so you're
going to be thrilled right the order
flows Trader now this is the order
Trader 3.0 this is the latest version we
just released this upgrade literally
about two or three weeks ago and it
works on ninja Trader 8 it's not
available for trade station or trade of8
or Sierra charts this is for or for
Ninja Trader okay ninja Trader 8 and
it's the volume footprint chart with 17
pre-programmed orderful tools I've
talked about a handful of them here but
there's many others and it's very easy
to set up right once you get Ninja
Trader set up which literally just takes
you a couple minutes to install it you
install the overflows Trader on there
you don't need templates or anything
like that because the defaults are my
defaults that I use and the the defaults
are set for e- Min a one minute chart
again you know I I talk about it in some
of the training videos on how to you
know if you're looking at something like
NASDAQ or um mini da some things that
you might want to adjust and normally I
sell it for $8.99 okay now the overflows
Trader it's like having me sitting
beside you telling you yeah there's
Market weakness here here there's a
market sweep Etc you know pay attention
it's like taking all my knowledge of
orderflow and putting it into a program
so you can see what institutional
Traders are doing in the market and that
was the whole point of me creating the
orderflows Traders I wanted to take what
I analyze the market with orderflow and
put it
into the software so the software can do
it for me so it can sort of take that
heavy lifting off of my shoulders but
having orderflow software is one thing
right you got to know how to use it so I
don't just give you the software and
send you on your way try and figure it
out I provide a lot of further education
on how to trade with orderflow you know
whether you know you're use an
orderflows Trader chart or you know
you're you have another software but you
just want the education you know the
orderflows trading course right I sell
this 297 on my website you're going to
get it for free it's 15 hours of video
instruction there 20 lessons is very
very useful in giving you the foundation
in understanding order flow you going to
get it for
free also I did a few years ago I had
did a series of 56 videos on Advanced
orderflow tricks tips and Analysis this
is what I call my inner circle video
series you get access to all of this
normally I sell just this video series
for $500 $497 exactly but I'm going to
give you access to that because you know
orderflow is so robust there's so many
different ways to analyze orderflow you
know I want you to be exposed to all the
little different nuances that you can
come
across right so you you'll be aware of
you know what this means in the order
flow what that means in the order flow
so it's going to help you out
tremendously now the software the
training and the video series together
it's almost 1,600 almost $1,700
$693 but I realize you know it's one
thing to learn from videos and books it
takes discipline and commitment though
right because you got to sit there and
put aside the time and say okay I'm
going to watch this video I'm going to
do this training what I found very
helpful for Traders is live training
where you can ask questions and for the
past two years I've been hosting live
weekly live user training sessions for
all the users of my software to join and
you know participate and I drive home
what I saw in the orderflow for the past
week you could ask questions about areas
you may be struggling with say you got a
simple question like Mike you know I
don't how you know I'm trading British
pound um you know what should I be using
as a setting um for this Market um you
know you're I'm there every Tuesday
night starting at 7 p.m. central Time
I've been doing this for two years it
goes back Lally to October of 2018
there's 92 episodes already in the
archives so even if you can attend you
can watch the replay okay so you know I
encourage everybody to attend you even
if you don't ask questions it's just
always nice to follow
along and you know this is what it looks
like in here all right you can so you
can see right the most recent one was
last week episode 92 October 6 2020 and
what kills me is I see other people
selling software then they want to
charge you to join their trading room or
extra training for for what you know I
mean what what's up with that you know
I'm buying your software you got to
teach me how to use it and that's why I
do these weekly Group Training sessions
is to get you up to speed on using it as
quickly as possible because I'll be
honest you know I used to do one-on one
mentoring I don't do that anymore
because of time constraints but you know
when I did it you know I was really hand
handholding people on on everything but
I found that I could reach more people
by doing a weekly session because you
know sometimes you know people got a
question on one or two things and it's
just easier to come to the session and
ask that question you know Mike I'm
using your software I'm I'm looking at
wheat you know on a f minute chart what
do you think is the most important thing
you know I'm been exposed to all these
different markets over many years um you
you'd be surprised that the markets you
know even currently the markets that I
that I trade are sort of off the Beaten
Track yeah my main focus is on Equity
indices but I also trade Commodities and
and other
contracts but more importantly you know
I I just can't get over the fact that a
lot of other gurus and stuff you know
want to charge yout extra for that some
charge $200 a month for one one session
a week you know that's ridiculous right
you're paying money for software you
want to know how to use it as quickly as
possible so when you add it all up right
the software the
training videos the Inner Circle videos
the weekly training you know what do you
want to put a price on that Weekly
training where you just come in you have
one you know not one-on-one on with me
but oneon-one with my group you know it
starts to add up
and you're not going to pay you know
$1,800 $1,700 it's just a one-time
payment of
$749 so go to orderflows docomo three
there's no monthly recurring payments I
know some people like to charge you oh
I'm going to charge you $200 a month for
as long as you know you're a member and
it just keeps recharging and you can
almost never cancel those things unless
you make all these phone calls and jump
through hoops now you will have to pay
your data fees and ninja Trader fees of
course um you know I'm just providing a
software if you want data you need data
to feed it but if you have a trading
account the data fees are are pretty
reasonable for most Traders and again it
runs on ninja Trader so if you're using
a paid version um you you're going to
have to buy a paid version from Ninja
Trader it will run on the free version I
have a lot of Traders using the free
version because they're basically all
they're doing is they're using ninja
Trader as their um charting platform and
they're executing either through the
broker's platform or another trading
platform
but you know see what other Traders are
saying you know other Traders are saying
you know Mike your orderflows Trader
software is remarkably helpful I can
clearly see now what's happening in the
markets you know zad says if you really
want to trade properly and understand
what on Earth is happening in any
markets orderflow is the path forward it
mic's experience and explanations it
clicks so what you do is you go to
orderflows domcom you go to this page
you scroll down now there's a lot of
there's videos and there's a lot of
charts and explanations of different
things you can read through that but
when you get you scroll down down you
get to the bottom of the page to get
started click this button now all right
you can see what you get here you get
the orderflows trader 3.0 you get the
orderflow trading course the orderflow
Inner Circle video series access to our
live group trainings as well as the
archives so if you can't attend and you
click that button it takes you to PayPal
it's processed through PayPal okay I you
know everybody's familiar with PayPal
right I don't get your credit card
information I don't want it it's it's
all pro handled through PayPal and again
it's just a one-time payment of
49 so you just go to orderflows docomo
3. HTML make sure you put the HTML on
the end so basically you got three
options one you can do nothing stay
right where you are now a year from now
watch another video of mine and think
where did this last year go I just
wasted a year of my life doing nothing
number two you could take what you learn
today go out there try to do it on your
own right trial and error for the next
few months and perhaps if you're lucky
you'll start to see some positive
results maybe you're doing something
right maybe you're doing something wrong
you know maybe you got some of the
concepts right but maybe there's a
better way of doing it okay number three
take my hand allow us to walk you step
by step through each part of the process
skip the trial and error right skip this
nonsense of blowing up accounts right
you shouldn't have to do that you but
people do right so if you do the work
you'll watch as your life and trading
transform right before your eyes so
which option is best for you right you
want to put the ball in the back of the
net so to speak right you want to score
basically but you got to think about
what motivates you right you want the
freedom to do what you want freedom to
go where you want freedom you know maybe
freedom to do nothing right this is me
with my family on vacation this past
summer we went to uh Mount Rushmore
right trading's given me that freedom to
do the things that I want to do with the
people that I want to do now I say
freedom to do nothing that is freedom
right I remember
when I was younger still single sitting
on a beach in Hawaii thinking God I'm so
bored out of my mind but that was
freedom freedom you know just do
whatever I okay I'll just go sit on a
beach today yeah I'm bored okay I'll do
something else you know trading gives
you that you know I I again I I told you
about my experience at JP Morgan it just
got to the point where it was just a
drag going into the office every single
day you know I mean yeah the money was
nice and you know some of the people
there were were nice to hang out with
but still it's like it really the fun
had just been drained out of me and you
know I wanted fun back in my life and I
wanted Freedom by trading but for myself
you know that's how I got that
freedom but as a special bonus today uh
for investor Expos I'm going to also
give you guys access to the orderflow
Playbook which is a course it's my it's
one of my favorite courses normally I
sell it for 297 I'm going give it to you
for free and there's actually I talk
about a bunch of trade setups in there
there about 10 setups that you know even
if if you just apply one or two into
your trading it's a very good uh very
good setup you could You' be amazed at
how your trading has improved so again
to get started go to orderflows
docomo 3ht ml and what you're going to
get you're going to get the orderflows
trader 3.0 the latest
version valued at $8.99 and you get the
orderflow trading course which is valued
at 297 I mean it's I don't say valued
this is what it actually sells at you
know I sell it literally every day at
that price you know people are buying it
I we give you access to that the Inner
Circle valued at $4.97 that's what I
sell it at right if people want to say
you know I might can I get access to
that yeah it can here's here's the link
you see what the price is but more
importantly you get the weekly live
group trainings you know tonight we've
got a a live group training going on at
7 p.m. central Time and you also get
access to the order flows Playbook
course which is also valued at
297 but again it's just a one-time
payment
749 go to orderflows docomo 3ht ml more
importantly again it's not I'm not going
to say oh you know a month from now oh
yeah I'm going to charge your credit
card another $199 or something you know
forget that stuff um you know pay for
something you shouldn't have to be
chained to it like oh my gosh you know
this is great but I got to keep paying
for it the rest of my life no you know
this is good software you pay for it
once right that that's how it should be
now if you're stuck around here you want
to copy of my book right go to
orderflows
docomo HTML enter your name and email
address and click this submit button
okay and it's going to take you to the
download page after you click submit
where you can download the book it's 150
Pages um you know it's funny we we
released this book in China right the
Chinese market a lot of interesting
interested people in orderflow there and
we're now in our second printing of the
book um coming up in a few in a few
weeks so it's a very good book and you
know you'll find stuff that is very
interesting now I don't normally like to
show trading results because you know a
p&l is useless because it doesn't teach
you anything about trading you know
people show me your p&l this is my p&l
from Friday I didn't trade yesterday
because of the holiday even though I'm
sort of kicking myself but you know I've
got a family with kids and I'm not
always able to trade the way I would
like to trade for sitting in front of
the screen for 6 hours because my kids
are doing home schooling not
homeschooling but you know the distance
e-learning this is my son he's sitting
at the end of my desk I had to buy a
little desk to put him on you know he's
got his laptop there and he's you know
here's I what he was doing here music
class or something but I don't get to
trade you know for consistent periods of
time like a five hour block a 6our block
you know I get a couple hours um you
know 8:00 a until about 10:30 and then
you know after lunch you I got to cook
him lunch and all that stuff um you know
maybe another hour or two later um so
you know I just trade ones and two Lots
at a time while my my son is over there
doing his his e-learning right you see I
traded this was October 9th this was
today it was last Friday right you yeah
41 contracts you know not every trade is
going to be a winner you I do get
stopped out 950 bucks you know minus the
commissions this is uh mini da you can
see right here
you know at the end of the day it was
you know plus about 700 something it was
a decent day you know just by sitting
around reading the order flow buying one
buy another one sell one sell one like
that in and out um you know I'm I'm
comfortable with my trading that I'm
able to do that and and and I want you
to be comfortable with your trading as
well so get started now go to orderflows
docomo three to get started you know
that's that's the main thing right is
you you you got to get started and you
know a lot of people in
life they don't get started they they
just sort of sit around and you know
wait for things to come to them and
eventually it just never comes to them
right they they they're sort of waiting
around looking for things to happen but
unless you take action nothing's going
to happen right you're going to ask
yourself what did I just do this past
year right what did I accomplish
right take control of your life you know
and for me you know trading gives me the
opportunity to do what I like to do in
life when I want to do it with my family
which is who I want to do it with right
it gives me that freedom you know if if
you want that freedom you know a lot of
people think well I got a full-time job
I can't just start trading the market
you know the markets trade beautifully
at nighttime right I showed you some
examples in this presentation of
activity happening you know at 1:00 a. 2
amm you could even trade during the
Asian hours which is like 8 p.m Etc the
markets are always open there there's
plenty of time for you guys to be
trading the markets so most importantly
you got to get started right I said
don't wait for more time to pass you
know we created the software you know we
don't charge $3,000 for it like a lot of
people do 3,500 we wanted to keep it
affordable right we wanted to you know
cover our expenses on programming and
testing and all that stuff um you know
don't really make much money off of it
but you know the whole point is to get
order flow out there to people so they
could improve their trading you know
people say well you know if you're such
a great Trader why don't you trade well
I do trade but at the same time if I
could help
people that helps me right because
sometimes I try to explain the market to
somebody and they just don't understand
it and I sort of got to figure out
another way to explain it then they get
it you know when the light bulb goes off
that's the greatest feeling in the world
um seeing a light bulb go off in a
Trader's head and they understand the
market but more importantly for me
sometimes when I'm trying to explain
something to to a Trader all right I'm
I'm they don't understand my direct way
so I got to sort of go you know take a
longer route go go over the side or
something then I start to realize
something that you know maybe I didn't
noticed necessarily before in the market
and ultimately I also learned something
so you know it goes both ways right I I
I missed the interaction
of trading on a trading floor you know
whether it's you on the C floor or in
the office you know the big trading
floors with other Traders this gives me
a way to interact with other Traders and
I also learn right so it's not all one
way you know here you know this is the
information I also learn in feedback
from other people like when I release
the orderflows trader 3.0 the thing with
value areas you know someone came back
to me and explained know this is
fantastic because now you know they
trade a certain way with Binger bands
that they they said something to me he
says oh you know I see this value area
move back into the Binger band it's gold
right it's it's it's a high percentage
trade for them you know I feel good
because sometime you know there's so
many different ways to read the order
flow I don't pretend to know everything
and you know if somebody teaches me
something in return that's great so this
is a way it's win-win for everybody so
more importantly get started and you
know I'll end it there for today so
thanks everybody for watching this uh
this training and I hope you guys have a
great day so take take care and enjoy
the rest of your day bye-bye